e aí
nós estamos ao vivo e em definitivo
e montamos em definitivo para começar
agora live das lives é o mac and cheese
live festival estamos aqui com meu amigo
luan murilo o nosso nacional
e aí
o conteúdo das páginas de contrabaixo aí
que vem nós tocar fica doida é
a música é muito boa noite boa noite
você que está em casa boa noite muito
boa noite estamos conversando aqui agora
a nossa live no mac and cheese festival
mix live festival com vários convidados
a gente vai ter aqui nós vamos aprender
a dançar murilo eu não sei se você tá
sabendo que a gente vai aprender a
dançar aqui ao vivo você tá sabendo
é mas agora você vai saber nem que não
queira hoje nós vamos aprender a dançar
aqui nós vamos aprender a fazer mágica
nós vamos tentar fazer mágica para você
aqui também que a gente já teve aqui
essa essa orientação e tô esperando aqui
o meu direito vou falar comigo no
microfone tava batalha achei o diretor
se você está a procura de uma ambulância
fala aqui com vocês vou botar esse
contrabaixo aqui
e faz um grupo vizinho para nós aí ó faz
um problema que é
e aparece aqui estamos hoje reunidos
aqui para mais uma noite mas online e
você vai curtir se apresentar pra você é
muito legal falei no micro-ondas são
cinco minutos se você tem um produto
sensacional para estar honrando está
entendendo 5 minutinhos hoje você vai
ver coisas incríveis que acontece em
cinco minutos é isso que nossos
convidados vão trazer para cá está nessa
aqui qualquer câmera que eu mudar ela
vera mundo ela muda então essa aqui está
nessa a
ah tá vamos ver rápido no gatilho é
nessa agora ou rápido se eu quiser nessa
tem rapidamente como um gato ao se
quiser perto do microondas tem também
vem olha lá acho que a galera gostou
dessa cama aí agora aqui temos nós tem
câmera aqui também e todo lugar tem
câmera estamos aqui na presença de
equipe sensacional que todo mundo de
máscara todo mundo tranquilo já já vou
está achando já já estou chamando o
nosso primeiro convidado aqui daqui a
pouco tudo bem com você você tá fazendo
que a gente vai levar altos na que diz
para casa todos nós estamos agora
patrocinados entendeu que eu pensava que
quando você era patrocinado por uma
marca você nunca mais precisaria comprar
aquele produto
eu já tava marcado na empresa barros
chegava lá falava o nome aqui eu já fiz
propaganda vou pegar aqui uma carrada
vou levar aqui para você alegria nesta
noite os meus convidados nós teremos
aqui improviso entendeu os barbixas não
está aqui fazendo graça humor que o
mundo está precisando em ultimamente
teremos aqui lexa também o música para
você para trazer animação desse seu dia
de hoje que eu não sei nem que dia é
hoje de tanto do lado que eu estou em
mas vai ser muito bacana vai ser muito
legal teremos também aqui mágica
entendeu eu vou tentar fazer o número de
mágica para você também não sei se você
vai vai gostar do meu número de mágica
mas eu vou tentar também beleza também
karol conká um vamos ter rashid claro
devemos rima rima você quer que eu vivi
m
e logo mais puxa da sopa galera e essa
bateria aqui era show né ah beleza
porque é
é muito louco muito louco
e é isso aí daqui a pouco está me
chamando o nosso primeiro convidado para
estar ensinando a gente a fazer um
remelexo né até mais meu cabelinho na
internet e
o detido já está me chamando para fazer
mágica para vocês não posso fazer a
mágica enquanto ele chega é melhor né
vou fazer um mágico aqui enquanto ele
chega vai receber o nosso convidado eu
vou pedir aqui ajuda do nosso amigo luan
né o luan vai me ajudar aqui traz aqui
meus meus aparatos de mágica para quem
não sabe eu trabalho com comédia há
muito tempo mas o meu forte mesmo é
mágica né eu era eu era eu trabalhava
sempre com aquele menino lá do bota aqui
para botar pode apostar pode botar aqui
a trabalhar com aquele menino do
sherlock holmes né se rapaz o meu deu
uma batida você conhecer o sherlock
homes
é muito gente boa rapaz muito bacana por
aqui
eu não conheci bicho será que homes
amigo nosso trabalhava para a gente ali
a gente vai fazer aqui o seguinte
e eu quero que você me amarre aqui
eu só quero que você me amar amar me
amarra é um feitiço eu tenho amarra tá
todo mundo tá vendo aqui chega de perto
chega perto por favor eu não quero
ninguém pensando aqui que eu tô mentindo
vai amarrar ó tá força força tá bom bota
nas ruas aí a marca outra outro não eu
não quero de forma alguma sair disso
aqui não de outros de outro não pode ser
só isso aqui tá fraco isso aqui tá fraco
e aí mais o nó
eu apertar mesmo assim né então tá ok ó
o brasil tá vendo o brasil joga joga
esse pano aqui em cima esse pano é que é
mágico a galera pensa que acorda mas na
verdade é um pano blog colocar aqui em
cima aqui ó
o que tem que apertar fraco tô sempre
aperta muito forte o pessoal tá mais as
coisa de mim vai tira
o [ __ ] vai vai vai bota aqui bota
aqui eu não aguento ficar muito tempo
não como é que tu fez isso que que você
arrumou aí [ __ ] meu irmão você fez
isso não acredito ai ai ai ai tá
apertado viu que tá apertado o felipe já
tá aí já já tá no ponto já pode chamar o
felipe pontiac pontiac de perto mostra o
detalhe vai ser um detalhe como é que a
minha montar
ah tá amarrado
eu só não sei como é que você aperta o
forte desse jeito tá meu amigo felipe
barbieri já está por aí
e aí
g1
a nossa coisas incríveis não sei que tem
alguma carta na manga para gente uma
cartinha na noite do mágico da dora
manga curta não tem como esconder muita
coisa aqui mas quantos soltar aí que a
gente já começa então então beleza então
vamos lá vai lá
as coisas incríveis que acontecem em
cinco minutos one two three valendo das
três meses já
se for vamos lá então cuidado muita te
ensinar uma coisa incrível aqui peraí
deixa eu fazer o suspense aqui pagar
para fazer o suspense aqui para galera
porque senão vai ser o tô entregando
demais eu trabalho aqui já chegar já
falando toma aí as mágicas na sua cara
toma aí não tem que valorizar o artista
intervalo comercial falando aqui agora
para vocês do nosso produto e ele vai
conversar agora coisas incríveis que
acontece em cinco minutos vamos embora
felipe barbieri ma lembro dos teus
beijar
e vamos lá
e eu vou tentar fazer com que vocês
entendam mais ou menos o mecanismo da
mágica aqui vamos pegar uma corda tá e
essa corda eu vou tentar cortar ela mais
ou menos lá no meio aqui ó e assim bem
no meio tá tá dando para ver que acorda
tá bem cortada no meio e eita lelê não
tá bem no meio o whindersson eu não sei
ai vamos tentar fazer o seguinte aqui ó
se eu juntar as pontinhas aqui a tal
mesmo tamanho tá vamos ver o seguinte ó
agora sim ela tá do mesmo tamanho só que
eu não gosto muito de errar mágica eu eu
não gosto então eu vou te ensinar como é
que a gente restaura essa forma eu vou
aqui dá um nó nela e olha só acorda tá
restaurada não tá
a base é
e esse olha só vamos focar bem aqui
nesse nós se eu pego ele e abaixo aqui
mas um pouco aqui porque você tá mágica
né se a gente continuar puxando aqui o
nosso sai e a gente tem uma corda eu
acho que vocês vão pegar eu vou tentar
mais uma vez vamos tentar cortar essa
corda lá no meio da metal mais ou menos
a metade eu quero fazer bem devagar
agora para ver se vocês vai comprar não
tá mesmo tamanho quem se importa né eu
vou ai meu eu tô um pouco nervoso eu vou
começar a mágica de novo aqui vou pegar
um pedaço de corda para ela mais ou
menos aqui eu quero picar bem essa corda
aqui porque eu tô começando a ficar
nervoso tá começando a ficar nervoso eu
em pó
nós vamos fazer mágica com baralho que
aí eu acho uma coisa muito incrível para
vocês como fazer o seguinte aqui vou
usar o fogo essa é a maneira mais
incrível desse fazer um mcqueen cheese
quando você não tem um micro-ondas mas
aí se tu só tem um pouquinho pouquinho
de talentos machos porque restaurantes
mais coloquei um pouquinho de álcool o
fluido e a gente tem que fogo fogo olha
só vamos tampar aqui para esse fogo
ficar mais eta eta que tudo que o
mcqueen cheese prontinho saquinho ele
vem quentinho ainda
ok google ver primeiro que você vou
comer primeiro com você eu já vou deixar
fala que eu tenho mais dois barros ele
dois minutos lá naquele grupo palma eu
consigo comer é isso aí
e obrigado obrigado aí eu falei que ia
fazer uma com baralho né whindersson eu
vou precisar da sua ajuda mesmo com o
dilei mesmo com o dilei eu vou fazer
tentar fazer você escolher uma carta
aqui tá para eu falar o william só pensa
em uma carta fala uma carta para mim vai
ficar isso eu vou falar que foi
combinado que que eu vou fazer eu vou
passar as cartas aqui bem devagarzinho
tá para você ver que são todas
diferentes tá e aí você vai falar para a
hora que você quiser selecionar uma
assim ficar bem aleatório vamos lá vai
pegar bem devagar aqui ó
eu vou fazer bem devagar para dar para
dar tempo vou responder quadrado lá vai
o barco essa o vou começar um dois três
e vou lá agora tá valendo agora tá
valendo a pena vamos lá bem jogar
e para aqui aqui aqui é eu não vou pegar
esse silêncio que eu já vi o três tá eu
vou pegar a próxima eu não vou olhar
memorize essa carta memoriza demonizou
vamos lá então na memória e deixa ela
aqui no meio seu está no meus dedos
estudava meus dedos a sua carta já vem
para o topo jovem para o topo olha só
bem devagar eu dou um corte nas cartas
estala o dedo ela vem para baixo aí as
pessoas falam por felipe tem vários dois
eu concordo com vocês todo baralho agora
se transformou da sua é isso aí ó
e olha só um copo vazio transparente
olha só uma bolinha hahaha rapaz agora
fez uma cara fez a mágica em 10 segundos
deu certo você é um cara viu tá fazendo
ao vivo aí espera aí obrigado espero que
tenham gostado da fio tu é doido meu
irmão eu nunca nem vi um número de macho
uma tela tão grande como essa
não deu para pegar aí tava grandão
conjunto pergunto você grandão aqui
parece uma batalha você é grandão aqui
parece uma batata mais quem quer mais
uma vamos fazer mais uma vou fazer uma
bem próxima da câmera aqui mais uma pra
gente finalizar vai bem próximo tá dois
elásticos whindersson um elástico nessa
mão o outro elástico nessa mão tá só que
eu vou entrelaçar eles eu vou deixar um
dentro do outro assim se eu passar para
baixo para cima para o lado para o outro
ele tá preso mas se eu assoprar
lentamente
e da travessa
e aí
o rapaz é muita falta do que fazer é
você ficar entregando livro olha só
devagarzinho a
oi sumiu
e depois fazer coisa preciso saber para
onde é que isso foi para o centro
cirúrgico para matar o felipe barbieri
vamos levar barbieri obrigado aí pela
pegada participação não sei que não
conhecia o barbieri ainda pode pesquisar
aqui no youtube nas redes sociais junto
nossa amiga e apanhar nosso amigo tamo
junto com ele para ver e nós igreja o
meu irmão obrigado tchau valeu
e valeu irmão agora que vai receber o
tchau daqui falou assim receber daqui 2
minutos o que é diferente
o quadro dele tá ligado lá hein
a galeria de casa
e obrigado por você está assistindo está
acompanhando aqui né estamos aqui com
nós na companhia do nosso amigo lula
murilo que não sei se vai fazer mágica
perguntei para você sabe fazer mágica
mas teremos mais convidado e a gente vai
saber mais o que é que eles vão fazer
aqui vamos ver se você luan também sabe
fazer que eu já sei requebrar vou
aprender a dançar o aprender a fazer
várias coisas legais estamos aqui
passando mais um momento quietinho nas
nossas casas espero que vocês fiquem em
suas casas também e se alimentando bem
aumentando a imunidade uma lógica porque
eu estava tentando me mandar uma lógica
eu só tomo eu gosto né eu só tomo
vitaminas e o agora são um homem de
dieta eu sou um homem que não topa comer
tudo que poderia comer e agora está
comendo só folhas alfaces e é isso aí
também tô com meu amigo robson que tá
treinando também para poder fazer as
coisinhas dele estamos aqui tendo nossos
hábitos assistimos nós
só curtindo férias como ninguém nunca
curtiu na vida rapaz já tô assistindo
assistir já passar em outro filme de
[ __ ] lá na rede social lá eu não sei
se pode falar pode né pode
a porta lá na netflix que é onde tem do
show adulto você pode assistir ela eu
não vou deixar hora arrastar para cima
tem que ser
e eu estava assistindo esse filme ontem
nesse filme de [ __ ] tô assistindo de
[ __ ]
eu vou assistir a tu não pode né amanhã
não teve nada não pode ela bloqueia na
tua casa tudo que eles multa e forma tá
bloqueado né na tua casa igual aquele
negócio quanto entra que clica aqui tem
assim você é casado deus me livre não
sai né ah tá bom hein eu gosto de
assistir gostava né assistir uns tempo
né quando você mais conhecer mais novo
você tem mais isso assim mas quando você
você vira adulto essas coisas você vai
começar a ser mais selecionado né com
isso assim essa essas paradas eu me
sinto muito em casa às vezes quando eu
boto um vídeo pornô que é sempre as
vezes que ela tá fazendo aqueles vídeo
amador é a rodrigo faro da televisão
você escuta entrega na casa uma pessoa
entendeu então tá sempre se sentindo em
casa né
e aí japa já maria aí tiago tiago
montalti é um dançarino sensacional um
cara que eu já vi eu acompanho o
trabalho dele no instagram nas redes
sociais ele é sensacional thiago você tá
aí você tá ao vivo entra aqui com a
gente vamos ver
e aí
o tiago é
[Música]
e aí o tiago
tu tá escutando jackson
eu tô escutando pronto bom nessa como é
que você tá meu irmão tá bem vamos tô
bem cara aqui tranquilão vamos dançar né
e essa quarentena aí o que que você tá
fazendo aí na sua casa aproveitando para
se profissionalizar mais ainda aprender
os fatos novos ou sei lá o quê ou tá
curtindo parada tá de boa
bom então cara eu tô aproveitando para
te dar mais ainda para tu dar meus
estudos na dança e poder te dar
movimento de novas coisas novas pra
galera na internet sempre tá podendo
crescer junto comigo aí aprendendo
coisas novas né e movimentações aulas aí
o que é que é novo para ti porque eu
assisto os vídeos é muito bom cara você
é muito bom você é [ __ ] eu queria você é
sensacional é uma classe me mudo não
para mim cara você pegar o que já existe
e transformar dentro da sua dança com
meu tio de dança então pega aqui de novo
coloca no meu corpo e transforma uma
galera que tá vendo de outra forma então
transforma aquilo em outra coisa nova
tem um faça uma transformação dos
movimentos que eu vejo na internet o que
eu estudo entendeu
ah entendi eu tava assistindo esses dias
uma uma coisa que eu vi no instituto é o
instituto brincante nóbrega que é uma
galera que faz muita muita dança
cultural assim sabe ele tava explicando
sobre como era aquela dança tipo o
bumba-meu-boi a veneno aquela dança que
é antiga né o maracatu aquelas coisas
que a antiga né que era mostrando que
era onde a a humanidade começava a
entender se ele era bicho era gente
entendeu a manifestação cultural dele da
dança de se reunir cultuar uma dança era
era o como é que fala como é que fala
era como é que fala quando vira a página
é um novo mundo como é que fala meu
irmão divisor de águas entendeu divisor
de águas tá muito bom aqui na minha
cabeça mas como divisor de águas para o
ser humano e entender que era diferente
do animal porque ele como tua né ele
dança junto ele se reúne para ver alguém
se manifestar então por isso que eu
fiquei muito interessante quando eu vi
seu instagram porque eu vi aqui em são
coisas novas e são movimentos que são
você estuda né de outras pessoas mas tem
coisas sua ali isso é muito legal cara
muito massa originária freeza também a
gente fazer essa fusão e traz de novo né
pra galera aprender coisas novas e
sempre da sua atualizando aí
a pessoa tipo bem rápido vamos dizer
assim tipo alguém que fala chega para te
falar assim a tiago eu não sei dançar eu
não tenho cintura solta mole esse molejo
que que eu faço
o cara seguinte tem os movimentos
básicos como qualquer coisa tem a base
né então vou te ensinar os movimentos
básicos e a partir dessa base a gente
vai tentando fazer coisas mais difíceis
né no caso aqui da minha apresentação eu
vou começar com uma coreografia fácil
ela vai para a intermediária e depois do
avançado então vai ser três níveis e a
galera vai ver qual que ela consegue
dançar
é demais é isso aí já era já era 15
minutos não
e no ciúme não cinco minutos então eu
posso chamar os cinco minutos então vou
chamar aqui para você o jackson minutos
vou voltar aqui no meu vou tirar a minha
cone aqui para conseguir dançar melhor
melhor ficar mais solto eu quero você
bem eu quero você feliz para cima alegre
porque enxergando você nós já estamos
viu não se preocupe com isso vamos né
vai lá puxa minha pronto
e ela é dramático em já está no ponto
as coisas incríveis que acontecem em
cinco minutos com tiago montalti vai
nessa thiago
e fala tu que eu tô
olá leitores
é sobre ela me provocar dor da frase
rede net income to be cutting edge essa
menina sabia exatamente ela me provocar
dor dataline rede subconsciente essa
menina sabe que é mulher vem com calma
[Música]
aí
a começar um compressão prévia não não
então ela não tem também trincada um
livro de yoga named ela me provoca toda
saliente rebolarem médico meu
subconsciente essa menina sabe quem é
matá-los a mente provocador das ali rede
de comer público sim entendi mas também
não sabe que é tá indecisa né mulher vem
com calma aí
o carinho impressão impressão e
pagamento bancário mais emprega no
brasil a diversidade acompanho colocar
esse bem devagar com brasão compras não
pensa ah não começa não compra então
preste atenção então pronto então é
e aí
a imagem de balança negócio não é
e assim jamais amiga vem para
brincadeiras envolvendo o que ela botou
bem jamais amiga vem para brincar o
dinheiro assim envolve no clima cocô tô
beijo até mais jamais amiga cadê tu
e aí
15 minutos bem aproveitado viu para
fazer o nosso mac and cheese rapaz eu
acho massa é como uma pessoa consegue
manter o sorriso né porque eu quando vou
fazer qualquer coisa que eu tenho que
concertar um pouquinho a minha cara já
fica eu vou malhar se eu vou dançar
agoniado e tô aqui tempo assim ó ó
e tem que ser alegre não passa aí cara
você aprender também vamos lá tem um da
coreografia simples tá vou fazer um erro
com braço né tá câmera lenta isso agora
vou fazer um erro manda comprar só fala
pro outro lado agora eu volto
e aí
e agora passa a mão no corpo aqui pra
cabeça um dois três quatro eu vou
repetir tudo de novo um dois três quatro
cinco seis sete de nove 23 anos quando
andou andou andou aí e o sorriso no
rosto sempre sorriso que alegre o
professor feliz então ouvidos não fala
comigo não é com você é
o negócio é que a gente vai ficar um
paciente que me acompanha chegar na
parte pra gente fazer essa parte da
curioso olha só acompanhando a gente
fazer isso que eu falei assunção depois
assim hoje falar porque eu tô cansado
original pega pega essa vai começar a
a previsão do tempo para trás a deus bem
eu canto bem de pagamento online agora
velocidade aumentar aumentar o
eu gosto tu vai sair então aí tem que
fazer pessoalmente eu sou eu
a água então é nós um abraço para você
bom trabalho fique bem aí nessa 40
desses problemas aí já já estão passando
essa essa loucura aí no mundo inteiro
tamo junto à praia nós nossa cansei e
eu cansei em meu amigo nosso mac and
cheese tem uma fome zinha de dançar né
porque a gente quando se esforça né eu
sou dançarino nato as pessoas sabe né
que a gente quando se esforça fica com
fome você vai querer de que nós temos
aqui ó de cheddar e calabresa nós temos
apenas cheddar porque tem pessoas que
não gostam de calabresa eu sou sempre
mais gosto sempre a soma para mim sempre
muito melhor posso viajar botar para
fazer meu direito eu tô com fome pode tá
bem eu vou fazer aqui ó você que os
passos rapidinho você vai resolver
e o papelzinho
e aqui ó
o meu papelzinho
nós já temos o nosso pratinho
eu removi aqui um segundinho
eu removi só um pouquinho para sair o ar
né para poder entrar e sair o ar e a
gente coloca aqui
15 minutinhos é exatamente aqui com
acabei de fazer tempo de fazer mais nada
fechou pronto até o nosso cinco
minutinhos
o que é só deixar o tempo passar curtir
as vezes uma música às vezes isso sei lá
e às vezes só curtir mesmo eu eu eu tava
lembrando das danças do rapaz porque eu
sempre fui dançarino né eu aprendi com
um banda de forró que as bandas de forró
tem dançarinos né são pessoas que estão
sendo feliz não importa qual momento da
vida estão é sempre um um sorriso no
rosto estão sempre dançando entendeu é a
música também sempre traz coisas boas
para mim eu acredito que quando você
pode ser bota ele de só acompanham
musicalmente o pastor falando
e aí
o meio vagarzinho qual o pastor falando
pastor tá pregando nessa noite é
e vamos um remédio aí no microfone é
possível é possível sim ok vamos esperar
aqui espera não já vou ir falando aí
e nessa noite maravilhosa sabendo que o
mundo está do jeito que está eu não é
mano long on
e já vai então reberg as senhorinhas
estão saindo de casa
e aí
já estão saindo de casa menos um
pouquinho quando você tava menos
e se puder sair de casa estão fazendo
caminhadas há três mente às vezes mente
que vai botar o cachorro para passear eu
tô vendo aí eu vejo a senhora puxando o
cachorro controle e pendurado porque a
senhora tava mentindo queria bater perna
bater perna no meio da rua
e agora quer se exercitar não se
exercitava agora está andando pelas ruas
e
e correndo o risco de pegar vírus o
período vírus que está fazendo a gente
está dentro das nossas casas curtindo
lágrimas nós vimos aí nós vimos a dor do
gusttavo lima era uma reise 9:00 é uma
rave estão nos obrigando a ir para rave
sem a gente querer ir você não está
percebendo mina do wesley safadão 12
horas da manhã é só para dormir em casa
eu tiro ficou deixando o
e não tem condições ia chamar ele para
vir aqui mas infelizmente não deu não
deu porque uma live não tem um produto
que a gente tem que ter olha tirulipa
o edson esse recado é para você anderson
estou com saudade de você se alimenta o
brasil você mija na nossa live está nos
agraciando aqui acabou a água meu amigo
por favor me ajude ajude seu poeta
[Aplausos]
o nosso próximo convidado diretor vai
falar aqui no meu no meu ouvido quando
eu posso chamar ela já já vai vir
e ela já já vai vir vai vir aqui se
apresentar falar com a gente alexia
vocês vão matar a saudade aqui daleste
também porque tá todo mundo e das suas
casas gente só vem live a gente só vem
lá e estamos agora ó faltando 44321
segundos para acabar o nosso prato
acabar de fazer o nosso prato que você
receber uma mensagem e eu vou receber o
alimento
o buda aumentar o retorno por favor do
micro que o roni aqui e quem quiser
adquirir né quem quiser comprar o seu né
que diz que é feito em cinco minutos
coisas incríveis que são feitas cinco
minutos uma delas acabou de ser feito o
time certo para cena
e aqui está fumar sim papai deixa aqui
papai me ver papai olha que legal você
abre este produto com essa voz vem olha
que legal você abrir este produto com a
facilidade olha isso olha isso então
mostrar para vocês aqui é o senhor é
e olha só que ai ai ai luan botar o seu
para fabricar amor quer que eu volte
para você você tá aqui eu posso eu posso
botar para fazer outro só deixar para
fazer aqui para o meu meu amigo aqui que
eu não gosto comer só sabe eu gosto de
comer companhia pessoa conversando
comigo almoçar jantar com a bater papo
e aí essa é a parte que eu passei para
primeiro que vocês que você tem a
oportunidade de comprar na record no meu
já está aqui
o vídeo
e aqui para cá e
o seu infelizmente tem que ficar fazendo
até o celular um pouquinho tá só
enquanto eu mas o senhor tá fazendo aqui
ó
e tem comentário do pessoal que está
assistindo aqui dentro vai botar aqui
para gente o pessoal vai vai colocar na
tela aqui agora o comentário do pessoal
que está assistindo o pessoal já viu que
eu sou elástico cintura praticamente
moto em joão paulo cardoso vou usar
todos os meus dotes em cinco minutos e
acabar com essa fome sadia live festival
muito obrigado joão paulo a adina
troncoso parabéns pela diversidade
apresentar nessa live eu estou me
divertindo muito em casa carinha feliz
buscando que coisa bonita em hashtag
sadia live festival se você quiser
interagir é lá klaus w clown room pode
me entregar um mcqueen fez aqui em casa
é
e com a mensagem mais não colocou o
endereço né então infelizmente a gente
não vai conseguir mas você pode comprar
pelo qr code klaus se você tiver ouvindo
agora essa mensagem para você e pessoas
que está assistindo mesmo que você ficar
na sua casa quer record aqui no cantinho
da tela você pode conseguir tem mais
comentários selecionar os comentários 1
e pode demorar aí tá tranquilo vou mas
se não hein
e a quando ele estava conversando aqui
mais cedo tinha plateia virtual que a
gente tava me falando tempo até virtual
é o que é o pessoal para conversar
comigo com meus fãs ah ah meu jovem pois
é é o certo bota aí na tela para mim por
favor e
o que é pior não tá escutando a tauane
para baixo para levar eu aí ó
a menina só tô vendo a minha em cima mas
aquela menina ali tá parada eu acho que
eu não tô interessante
olá olá
oi boa noite vários lugares diferente
nossa adorei a paleta de cores ficou um
quartinho azul no quartinho rosa um
quarto degradê um quarto com aquele
rapaz chegou tchau hein não tchau chegou
eu espero a reação dos tchau então tá
bom em pessoas vão rindo descoordenado
aparece aquela senhorinha da igreja
batendo palma fora do ritmo gente eu não
tô conseguindo escutar vocês mas vocês
estão me escutando então eu quero olhar
muita palma agora agora todo mundo fica
feliz muito obrigado você estaria aqui
com a gente continue acompanhando tá bom
né
e aí
e continua galera e agora vou te amar
nosso próximo qualidade fica aí não sai
daí já já hoje eu vou sair de novo aqui
já posso chamar diretor posso continuar
comendo enquanto chama tá bom viu tá top
vem para cá vem para cá deixar o
eu cheguei cheguei cheguei cheguei tá me
ouvindo tá me ouvindo tá ouvindo batman
o futebol como é que você tá minha amiga
você tá bem tá comendo né queria comer
né mas daqui a pouco eu vou comer eu tô
bem eu tô ótima tô vendo aí a sua sala
tá parecendo um clipe
e é minha cozinha não sei o quanto
maravilhosa minha tá louco eu acho que
nem eu acho que é assim com essas duas
toda hora deixa assim
o amor de deus meu amigo pessoal próxima
produção tem essas músicas mas você
volta depois de acharem por aqui como é
que você tá você tá bem o que que você
tá fazendo esses últimos dias você tá
tranquilo olha acabou de fazer outro
mega-tins ele já pode pegar viu é o seu
como é que você tá como é que tá os
cachorros como é que tá seu marido
aparecer ela tem um cachorro chama da
horinha júnior da hora e aí tem o dalri
júnior
eu tenho eu tenho da hora tenho
simpático dantas o contente da silva e o
pode ter júnior dela chama contente pode
crer da hora da ori junior faz uma coisa
eu aprendi os passos de dança aqui com o
tiago eu queria saber o que que você vai
me ensinar hoje se você tem movimento
para mim também
eu tenho eu tenho um movimento de lá
para fazer essas sua raiva mexer se tu
tiver se a tua quer que fosse apresentar
foto tiver uma coreografia eu queria que
você me apresentar se aí uma uma parte
passo da coreografia para também não me
fazer passar vergonha aqui também né ao
vivo
e não mas amigo você tem malemolência
malemolência se tem suingue do nordeste
tá internada não entendeu né
o que vai passar a mão solteira sou mais
eu meu bem é filando e você me perdeu
pode então admirar isso quiser ficar ir
quando eu sou tocar ou dançar para
seduzir eu meu deus meu deus até o chão
e assim ó rebola assim viu aí tá ótimo
tudo que eu precisava dançar hoje
a dança aí amigo vai cedinho e abre a
perna dedinho abre a perna dedinho
apenas 1
o dedinho a na perna espera aí espera aí
espera aí bota bota a câmera aqui bota
nas pernas também
e aqui nas pernas dedinho abre as pernas
e dinho abre as perna que cor dançou
dançou dançou legal
eu gosto de levantar agora tô com inveja
de você comendo aí então fazer o meu a
gente tá aqui comendo rapaz ir tá
gostando do bebê é show de bola viu como
é
oi como é meu diretor só isso você
receber informações aqui tá bom eu
queria dar só os colher adianta chamar o
desafio eu vou chamar o desafio agora
você já tá preparada hum
já tá preparado nada amigo tô aqui no
ponto já para cantar dançar requebrar
subir na mesa coisas incríveis que
acontecem em cinco minutos com lexa
desde a sua própria casa iluminada vamos
embora
e aí
a moral play on
e vivem assim para de marra me deixa
dançar não é meu dono para vir me manda
o seu vou me acabar perdão mané só vai
poder me olhar o sandro e rebolando
chamando atenção jogando o meu cabelo
evento de ser é hoje que vai passar mal
solteira eu sou mais eu meu bem afilando
e você me perdeu pode então admirar isso
quiser ficar aí mas quando o meu so
tocar eu vou dançar para ser agora
aquele passinho ao em um denso aí eu dei
a senha denso é acham eu subo tinha lhe
mostrar o meu poder de sedução desce de
novo teste de novo faço você dele a
rebola e só para te provocar o deus eu
tenho eu
e até o chão é um sub funcionando e
mostrar eu faço você dele a revolta de
prova para de marra me deixa dançar não
é meu dono para vir me mandar só vai
poder olhar e rebolando chamando a
atenção jogando o meu cabelo é hoje que
vai passar mal solteiro sou mais eu meu
bem assim então admirar e se quiser se
quiser ficar aí mas quando o meu so
tocar eu vou dançar você que tá em casa
e desce até o chão e
o meu padrinho descendo são ela dessa eu
desço fácil você de lina rebola rebola
os dias só para te provocar sou eu sou
eu dessa eu sou funcionando e mostrar o
meu poder de sedução eu desço eu desço
eu desço eu vou parar para de marra me
deixa dançar para de marra me deixa
dançar e
e aí
eu parei na posição
quem está comigo aí amigo cadê meu amigo
que o leque pode comer vou bacantes
é a mais uma é mais uma
e mais o quê música
e aí
e olha a gente pode cantar que a gente
possa desafiar agora cantar para gente
aqui ouvir o que que você acha tô
conseguindo
é mas ele vai de boca cheia é o desafio
do max steel na boca né que mais gosta e
e como os caminhos você mais gosta vamos
lá
e daquela que enfim todos têm mas eu
adoro quando começa sempre falar leque
aí pomba bom acho que eu mais gosto
eu acho que vai chamar conhecimento
daleste né chama tipo dá para fazer
aquele tipo assim porque tem aqui pode
fazer um
e ai eu fico 30 segundos olhando porque
o escudo o meu próprio retorno dez
minutos depois aqui ó
o que é isso até midinha
e fica tá tá aqui vai fechar é isso que
eu tô querendo aprender agora como é que
é isso aí
e a mexer assim tá então só aparece aqui
também te deixa coisa parece que vem um
pouco com a pessoa né parece que vem um
pouco com vocês isso aí é sem fazer
outros movimentos tem bem é tem isso
para mim tá bom o teu tá pronto vezes
nesse e apitou fazer
e aqui fica muito espinho só balangar
assim assim é lá lá né
ah tá certo tá bom tá bom cara a bunda
toy toy aí sobe assim ó é isso é soltar
sabe aquela da tremidinha também que faz
assim sou tá assim que eu vou ficar
faltando aula de funk aqui agora lá lá
aqui aqui tem que respeitar também sabe
sim vai vai vai vai logo vai logo tu fez
para gente a primeira vez o
ó tá vendo meu desafio dos bons obrigada
tamo junto de amiga obrigado viu
obrigada você viu que deus fala com essa
energia maravilhosa obrigado a fadinha
também por unir todo mundo aqui estou
muito feliz a gente tem que falar disso
aí mesmo porque essa dia uniu a gente
aqui tá todo mundo dentro das suas casas
tá todo mundo respeitando aí a
quarentena para não oferecer risco a
ninguém tá todo mundo tranquilo e a
sarinha juntou toda essa galera
talentosa aqui para tá ao vivo aqui para
você no sadia mac and cheese live
festival obrigado leste um beijo para
você dá um beijão no rimei um beijo nos
cachorrinhos estamos junto é nós brigada
beijão
ah tá
[Música]
oi hoje é só aprendizado aqui já
aprendemos
e a dançar o tiago aprendendo a dançar
com a leste aprendendo fizemos mágica
aqui até mais que foi feito aqui tô
cansada hein pego aqui para mim cansei
mesmo quanto o desafio tem não tem
desafio nenhum ginasta né eu
fisiculturista não né que eu não vou
conseguir ficar levantando peso em
o desafio olha
eu botar aqui o meu meu fone tá
conversar com o diretor daí diretor fala
comigo meu meu deus que ele fala só no
meu ouvido você não escuta então para
meu deus ela tá na bala já tá no ponto a
letícia gomes não sei se você conhece
você ainda não conhece mas ela é uma
grande profissional da maquiagem ela
deixa qualquer pessoa qualquer na
verdade eu vi ela fazendo a cara dela
então se transformou em johnny depp olha
tanta gente tanta gente essa minha se
transformou e ela tá aqui também
participando aqui com a gente e vou
chamar ela agora bota letícia aqui para
mim para falar com ela leite se você
está aí ó
[Música]
oi oi
oi oi tô aqui tudo bem tudo bem como é
que você tá eu também graças a deus que
legal conhecer você que legal conhecer
você e ver você sim de letícia mesmo
porque eu já vi você com vários rostos
diferentes na internet é hoje eu tô de
letícia mesmo sempre aparece alguém
impressionante que foi que tu tirou esse
negócio de se transformando as pessoas
em 2016 eu vi uma italiana que se
transformar em vários personagens eu
achei aqui incrível e é difícil me
impressionar com as pessoas elas nossa
você não porque eu já tava ela fica
coisa na internet e aí e aí impressiona
que nem eu vai atrás para poder aprender
fazer o negócio é só desse jeito aí
também eu eu as coisas você fazer tudo
eu vi alguém fazer algum lugar e fiquei
meio deles o que que eu não sei fazer
isso ele vai só que você faz
é porque eu vou falar em coisa como se
fosse tipo de você pinta também você
desenha também pinta porque é muito bom
o jeito que você faz que artista
bom então todo mundo me pergunta isso
quando eu faço transformações mas na
verdade eu sei desenhar mas não sou nada
assim profissional sabe o meu negócio é
com maquiagem mesmo é sim letícia silva
tesão pelo amor de deus você você faz
umas paradas muito louco você tem uma
surpresa para gente aí
e eu tenho espero muito que você gosta
de surpresa já desafio é uma surpresa
antes do desafio é isso
e pode ser pode fazer parte do desafio e
depois dá um acrescentando aí então vou
pedir para saltar aqui o diretor você já
quer ir para saudar então posso voltar
aqui para você e você que não conhece a
letícia você vai conhecer agora de um
jeito muito legal porque ela se
transforma meu irmão só presta atenção
no talento essa menina aqui vamos lá dar
play on
a natalie é
e ai meu deus fica no começo não faz
isso com você é
e aí minha boca não é
tu não viu ela que eu fui muito bom eu
quero assistir que legal cara como você
faz para poder ir para ficar aí como eu
acho é como é que faz isso como faz para
ficar aparecendo alguém desenhando na
cara então parece difícil né mas não é o
uso técnica de luz e sombra é igual
quando você vai desenhar mesmo mas assim
eu sempre olha a foto da pessoa no caso
olhei sua foto já analisei e aí onde tem
sombra eu vou colocar no meu rosto
também com o contorno é tipo luz e luz e
sombra mas eu faço contorno e iluminação
como corretivo e pode ir para o face
é porque o tom da minha pele tem que ser
então tipo tem que ficar na posição
zinha né você não pode tipo vir assim se
tem que fazer assim eu só uma posição
zinho né
é exatamente tem um saco de luz também
ângulo eu sempre fico assim de frente
porque se eu virar um pouquinho seja ver
a imperfeição tá né entendi também tu
pode fazer alguma coisa do tipo já fazer
a pessoa de lado né se tu quiser tipo já
faz um pouquinho de lado né assim
e aí
um por um tempo monalisa aí a mona lisa
já não preciso me transformar em três aí
eu tenho que fazer de ladinho assim já
já vai desenhando se vendo de lado já
cheguei aqui transformar ela entende as
coisas incríveis que acontecem em cinco
minutos aqui no sadia mcqueens live
festival você tem uns truques aí para me
ensinar também alguma coisa eu tenho
sempre truquezinhos para você é bem
simples mas que faz toda a diferença tá
bom então vou soltar aqui tá
ah tá bom ela ficou pronto já tá demais
ficou pronto aqui estou eu para dizer
para você que coisas incríveis acontecem
cinco minutos a letícia em lei da o
placar patrão é
e aí
bom então olha só eu normalmente quando
eu me transforme homem a maioria dos
homens que eu já me transformei eu tive
que diminuir o vermelho eu tive que
fazer o contrário né comentários nos
lábios e aí eu gosto de fazer mesmo no
meu dia a dia assim eu gosto de dar uma
aumentada neles porque acho que fica
bonito né com maquiagem de sempre dá um
jeitinho e aí eu gosto de pegar um lápis
de boca eu tenho um colega escuro que o
batom que eu vou passar então né você
você consegue se maquiar com o negócio é
esse aqui é o
ah tá focando é esse mesmo tá bom então
você vai pegar o lá em qualquer um
segredo daqui você fazer uma linha um
pouquinho a mais um pouquinho fora da
sua boca ó
hum hum e vai contornando toda sua boca
claro
a gastar gastar o equipamento todinho
aqui na eu deixei um pouquinho mais
ainda né mas é legal é
o homem não tem labra
e a maioria não você acredita não tem
que acontece rapaz foi eu me diferente
do piauí pi
e aí
e aí você vai pegar o batom que tá aí
o meu batom
eu tenho batom aí né é isso aqui né
e isso é com ele tá aqui vai pegar e vai
passar por todas a boca só que no caso
você pode passar um pouquinho em cima
também do lado que você passou lá
g1
eu acho que ele vai passar para mim
pegar umas 7:30 tomate
o manchester chelsea blusa do psg
e o que vem sair com a gente de quem né
e aí
e olha
e olha só deixa eu ver você é
e aí vai ter como que motor menino ai ai
eu vou aí não quando tem aquela pelinha
na boca sabe vítima merda comigo também
agora
hum hum e agora cuidado na lan house
dentes em um
a saber 1
e ai que lindo legal é que nem precisa
deixar o seu maior lado maior ainda
agora sim agora sim é
e eu tô amei obrigado você também
[Música]
obrigado por deixar o meus lábios tão
bonito
e agora me sinto não tem a minha
autoestima também melhorou agora e eu me
sinto melhor com meus novos lábios
obrigado por você me ajudar nesse
momento mas eu eu amo me maquiar claro é
mais difícil que você fez foi mais
difícil olha que deu bastante trabalho
foi pabllo vittar muito trabalho então
né então demora mais em
é exatamente isso que eu acho engraçado
que você acha engraçado que quanto mais
engraçados com esse facebook quanto
menos detalhes tem a pessoa para me
transformar mais difícil é então achei
um pouco conta do mas eu tenho um risco
zinho faz toda diferença né se você faz
aqui parece até mais velhas que você faz
eita carai mas deu mais trabalho para
deixar todas as minhas linhas assim mas
não é tranquilinha né para não ficar
aquela coisa é tão comportada tão pesada
que eu o importante é você deixar uma
linha mais pesada mesmo mais forte para
dar sorte com seu rosto porque eu vou
deixar segundo só
é apertadinho de fazer eu também
obrigado obrigado tá cuidando obrigado
agora mais a gente vai conhecer o
trabalho tá não esqueça acompanhar ela
quando você vê um vídeozinho aqui é uma
pessoa que não é a pessoa é o desenho a
pessoa ela que está por trás disso aí
muito feliz de tá aqui com você consegue
tamo junto esse aqui é o desafio meu
amigo são coisas incríveis que acontecem
cinco minutos tá
quem gostou deixa eu fazer aí você
também em ver se você também tem uns
lábios grandes não é bonito rapaz não
rapaz não pode deixar realçar às vezes
não é embelezar é realçar entendeu
porque a beleza ela está sempre a pessoa
diz que ela tá bonito pessoas gostam né
gostar todo mundo gosta neném então não
é já sabe o que é exatamente como eu
sempre quis ver hum agora a parte melhor
né
é a cereja do bolo capa para sua esposa
em casa sabia que que você tá
trabalhando mesmo né porque de repente
chega a mais uma aqui ou mas só se
maquiagem que é isso aqui está está
feito também xi meu amigo a boca aqui
vai um litro de negócio aqui quem aí
olha aí ó olha isso que coisa linda tá
todo mundo de boquinha obrigado letícia
pelas suas dicas sempre vai ajudar a
gente a cada dia mais eu queria chamar
minha pátria visual para poder ver
conversar com a minha galerinha oi
pessoal agora já já tô ligado como é que
faz já voltava logo esse antes que daqui
10 segundos chega
o olá vamos lá tem que segurar chegou
chegou lá regular galera tava tá ouvindo
agora aquela linha tá tá travada galera
que legal que vocês estão aí é muito bom
olhar conversar com vocês dizer que tá
várias carinhas conversando e eles não
podem ir dar tchau é por isso que eu
chamo e saio porque eu chamo ele sai não
tem condições ali ainda tá parada menina
é isso aí gente obrigado eu sei que eu
gosto de mim mas obrigado a cada dia
mais está não sabe como é que tá a
galera do youtube tem
tu tem
e vamos ver matheus coelho boa noite
whindersson nunes boa noite galera do
chat hum não tem um apetite mateus qr
code está aqui ó
um bom dia para você
e aqui aqui é o qr code você pode pedir
o seu próprio mecanismo exata a
e botou qr code na tela você pode
comprar tá entendendo eu vou chamar para
vocês mais uma pessoa sensacional para
falar aqui com a gente eu diretor meu
amigo rachid está no ponto é isso aí
irmão vou mandar para virar samba vai lá
eu tô aqui com luan encantando para você
para você uma certa para você eu vou
chamar o meu amigo e eu agora é o meu
amigo didi didi didi
o alemão
oi e aí como é que tá é isso os caras do
rap já falou diferente quando entra mano
tá ligado tá ligado como é que você tá
tá bem aí
eu tô bem tô bem na medida do possível
na medida do possível né mas bem na
medida do possível que hoje é o que tá
dando para fazer mesmo eu tô muito feliz
de estar aqui com você né é quando a
gente já anunciou no festival a galera
já começa a comentar galera já começa a
falar vou esperar a hora do cara chegar
vai esperar a hora do cara chegar tamo
junto estou muito feliz e honrado que tá
falando com você aqui ó
se você é louco eu que tô feliz por
demais tô falando seu trabalho admiro
demais arte do improviso também gostei
do que você fez aí tem perguntando para
você já saiu já foi porque assim ó a
gente lá no nordeste a gente tem as
coisas semelhantes nessa é a embolada é
o repente né então a gente é acostumado
com um joguinho de palavras e acho que
ele é todo mundo que deve saber rimar na
hora mais mas assim que o jogo de
palavra a gente aprendeu um pouquinho
com você aprender esse negócio de rima
a compra que eu vi uma entrevista uma
vez de um parceiro e que se chama do
canal né que é um um rapper aqui de são
paulo que é referência assim para muitos
da minha geração e da nova geração em
viu eu li uma entrevista dele de uma
revista e meio que que ele copiar a
ideia mas a partir do daquilo ali várias
coisas me inspiraram inclusive muito do
que é feita no nordeste e no norte do
brasil também é grandes repentistas me
inspiram demais até para fazer improviso
porque então eu aqui a gente consegue
juntar uma coisa que vem lá de fora vem
da gringa mas também com a riqueza da
brasilidade tá ligado isso é importante
50 eu tava conversando com o thiago
sobre a dança mas para gente com a
música a mesma coisa a conversa a quadra
é a galera começou usar mas a galera de
cordel que usava né o a quadra né eu vou
falar não sei o que lá para mim lá
entendeu é uma coisa que eu puxo
e jogou na música dele botou aqui ficou
bonita para poesia ficou diferente e tal
é mais a gente tem inúmeras combinações
né como por exemplo na embolada que é
tipo a primeira rima com a ter só
segunda rimam com a sétima é vai ficando
cada vez mais complexo só que o cara
sertanejo né o cara do sertão isso aí é
outro nível porque cabeça e tempo para
pensar onde você não tem muito o que se
agarrar o que entreter né aí os caras
são bom embolado eu acho legal acho
bacana vamos lá meu irmão você pode
trocar mas é isso aí é isso aí é outro
nível é faculdade faculdade a gente tem
que aprender fazer vamos lá meu irmão tá
com você agora é
e aí bacantes live festival rapid
whindersson nunes está quase dom para o
ritmo do meu dia a correria igual e
depois não é
o que ela tu fiquei de olhar o whatsapp
motivo para ficar mentindo para o alto
vem comigo por favor ruas de deus me deu
mais coragem que ritmo brasileiro e
rebola rápido eletromagnéticos
o meu filho pp com menina querem nível
outro livro esse amor de volta português
possível aí como é que foi profetizado o
precisa de nada mais a gente se falou
agora ela mineiro ruas namorado seu
namorado é
oi hahaha e o da hora de boa já é uma
batata total muito bom é isso aí na sua
batalhar tem que começar para saber o
que que eu vou dizer que eu tenho que me
inspirar vai vou chamar vou chamar os
objetos aqui para você e você vai me
matar porque aparecer separei os objetos
ele não olhamos objeto exato olha aqui
na tela está aqui do lado aqui
exatamente é isso aí ó
me mande mande mais você consegue já ir
começando falando sobre cheddar demorou
eu vou rimando ele não tem que dar o seu
nome e pediu para eu ir marcondes ch
está ligado minha rima é boa igual beijo
na rua para mim vou rimando que nem
cinco minutos daqui a pouco eu vou rimar
nem fez os cara ali tudo louco vai se
objeto vem aí então deixa eu fazer o meu
papel de emitir porque não vai logo
mandou para mim o que um estilingue eu
tô mandando aqui rapidinho não para a
seguir tu era uma tiara mas não mas não
eu não caio não se esqueça aquilo ali é
uma fase a dor desse brasil então
e aqui a rima de para o whindersson
motor tá fazendo uma massagem até na
cara é dessa forma irmão eu dormi
prometo perto do coração então manda um
recado para os moleque sou infinito vai
escutar o que rap na festa do bem como é
que é da fita aqui mais mandando a
poesia mais bonita deixa os cara maluca
maluca e depois te mando assim que nem
mandou essa peruca despediu de aqui não
é pesadelo sinceramente isso tá
parecendo até meu cabelo e vai embora
dessa forma então a gente se revigora
porque integrado igual a luva de boxe
que a gente não vou mandar isso aí deixa
eu fazer meu papel aqui no botão então
abajur me faz
é daquela menina talentosa mas muito
talento da banda também vou mandar no
improviso aqui nesse momento que segue
no luso determinado de janeiro 2019 que
é ele mandou logo o que o pé de pato por
que raio de novo rápido depende próprio
corpo espera não no sofá pode mandar o
objeto porque eu não paga na rima sempre
complicado né é não dessa forma não tem
controle na minha rima rápida que
transforma quando o pai tudo no
improviso valência na plateia seis o
piso eu não sei o nome daquele comigo do
seu modelos
o que é compromisso não é um ouvir então
é meio assim eu vou mandando a perdi a
rima porque não conseguir pensar com
nada por movie assim iluminar e ele tá
pulando ali o muro onde ele vai menino
se preocupe com o futuro isso que ele tá
pegando aqui debaixo semana enquanto
passa vai tocando ali eu entendi sua
escolha foi ali no matinho pegar uma
folha se cuida vai criar sua parada
traiçoeira pode dar cólica no bebê que
eu estive ali arrumando que eu tô no
meio eu não sei o que eu tô falando o
danilo vai mostrando isso vai levantando
vai danilo tô aqui te esperando
é um rashid ah que legal você quer me
complicar ficou o negócio errado é uma
piada o que meu deus meu deus meu deus
como é bom ganhar dinheiro vai vai vai
manda o lula murilo filho você deixou na
sua casa sem trabalhar que legal nunca
vai acabar meu deus e
e eu tô quebrado nessa live quando ela
aqui do lado tô de boa tá acabando meu
irmão eu sabia botar contagem regressiva
três quatro e acabou acabou cara muito
barulho para o maior rezende sabe que eu
esqueci de falar da minha rima de mandar
um pessoal no comentário aí na minha
rima não é porque tem que mandar para
ele vai atrás do meu comentário é isso
aí ó
nós tamo junto é nós fazemos a gente
você faz qualquer coisa mesmo isso aí
brasil que trabalhar junto estamos em
contato é verdade que precisar fale
comigo tamo junto vamos ligar vamos
fazer essa foto para você pode ver aí
tamos junto é nós vai continuar quiser
eu posso acabar bem tá bem quem já viu
de hoje felipe barbieri mágica aqui para
vocês vocês a letícia se maquiar com a
boca carnuda dona bonita mas a próxima
aqui agora com a gente karol conká karol
com k k
e aqui para tombarem pode vir karol
conká cabelo quando eu estou recebendo
meu amor enquanto isso vamos ver tá me
escutando então quando você me escuta eu
vou falando para você me conhecer na
música já que é para tombar tombei de
sair desfilando com as roupas de cama de
cada hotel que eu estava enrolado em mim
isso aí acha que tá então veio foi nesse
momento que eu conheci você e até hoje
eu acompanho você cara tá muito forte
enquanto você não me escuta me
e agora saiu hein tá saindo daí o jair
escutem você como é que você tá eu tô
bem e você na medida do possível
caminhando em caminhando dentro de casa
né só pode ir a correr para a sala da
sala do quarto e assim gente vai como é
que você tá tá com a pena você tem que
ficar tranquila e tem mantido uma paz na
sua cabeça embora já que os últimos
acontecimentos não deixa a gente manter
paz hora nenhuma mas você conseguir se
concentrar um pouquinho sim coisa que a
gente estamos todos aqui no meu estudio
nesse momento onde eu fico o tempo
inteiro e eu gosto de fazer minha
produções realmente é o momento a gente
passa por um momento muito difícil mas é
importante também manter o foco na fé na
esperança e tudo que eu tenho de boa
o exame quer fazer música e ali nas
pessoas e me cuidar e cuidar do próprio
corpo ele falou que que é uma boa a
música né nossa arte de escutar o que a
gente tá passando nesse momento né que a
gente guarda muito pra gente não
consegue conversar com um amigo que às
vezes a gente não tem liberdade para
falar alguma coisa com um amigo bota na
música bota escreve batom sanpaku faz
grito faz beleza a gente pede para jogar
de todo jeito você é muito agradecer
muito bonita hein adorei obrigada eu
mesmo a deus por entender que legal que
você vem aqui conhecer com certeza eu
vou chamar o seu desafio aqui tá fechado
vou falar para vocês aqui ó
os incríveis que acontecem em cinco
minutos agora na voz de karol conká
vocês vão ver que ela tem para gente aí
carol você o junto play então eu tenho
preparado muito para colocar pode
levando todos aqui eu não tenho
apresentar do meu tempo muito para
estudar produção musical agora porque eu
estou aqui no microfone cantando então
tem interessante mostrar para vocês eu
tô bem básica viu gente tá aprendendo
então vou mostrar aqui para vocês uma
pequena brincadeira assim do outro lugar
que a gente pode fazer e você vai remar
junto também porque a sofia vai com você
também aqui ó ok vamos lá vamos ó
e aí
o papa mas eu tenho só a batida já foi
para mostrar para vocês escutar alguma
coisa né com certeza não é
e não volta mais carro bateu uma vontade
de mandar ok sim sim
me avisa tá geral perguntando se você
vier para que serve para cozinhar camisa
você quando tudo isso acabar quero te
ver não passar vontade deu para perceber
ouvindo isso acontecer estou à vontade
de matar live aqui o vídeo para
agradecer a deus que ela entendeu aí
é só tem agradeço que é agora eu quero
ouvir você remar também eu vi aí meu bem
estou aqui em cima da minha casa eu
estou aqui na casa para morar na gaveta
da minha casa uma live que você tá em
outra por causa do
e aí
e em cima lá no estúdio dela e eu estou
na minha casa mensagem eu tô em cima da
minha casa eu tô em cima da minha casa
eu tô em cima da minha casa e dá mais de
barra da minha casa e mandar mensagem
mandar minha casa de boa aqui com meu
amigo lua e prendo aqui com meu amigo é
se você quiser ogata para você carol oi
prima da minha casa em cima da minha
casa eu vou ver a dancinha e
tá calor né
eu sei qual é o nome da tarde novo peixe
uma piada em cima da minha casa é
tu não já tem coreografia você viu que
aquele negócio ligeiro fez uma mega
coreografia gente foi difícil de fazer
se deu tô aqui ó vem vem jogou e vai dar
minha casa dizer que ter ocupado em cima
da minha casa minha casa eu amo
whindersson obrigado amor só espero que
você na sua que na sua aqui na essa
pessoa quarentena você fosse mais ainda
tudo que você tiver diferentemente das
suas músicas você tem mais música para
fazer para gente eu tenho inclusive o já
escreveu uma música nova em breve vou
lançar para vocês também viu mas agora
eu vou cantar uma aqui agora vou cantar
uma que eu sei que tá todo mundo assim
com esse mesmo sentimento de saudade
saudade de tudo saudade é só botar aqui
para que eu tô né dj am
e aí
[Música]
o acabamento e você passa seu jeito
então dar você nem me olhou eu acho que
esperar você conseguiu não falou cuidado
de tempo que você sabe que eu sempre
assistir nossos aturar errei eu errei eu
que tem que fazer durar mais nas unh
delícia que normal
e aí
a entrada você faça seu jeito de andar
você melhorou
e eu não falo sempre prestativo e já
assisti nosso segurar e eu e eu tivesse
que fazer orar mais e mais liberdade ele
tá não esquecer mais não já acabou já
não sente saudade daí ele não vai sair
mais não é
e aí
e aí você vai é nós que vira simpática e
tudo bem tá tudo bem aí
e aí
a menina
olá eu sou
[Risadas]
e aí
[Música]
e daqui valeu pode eu falei faz assim
vai ficar não consegui falei que eu tô
cansada só cozinhei com algumas você
preparou mandar mais eu tô quando ele
tem vídeo novo a gente entende que você
tava de chegar na minha olha também nem
sei lá
não tem nada para falar
o meu daqui a vida é um milagre
[Música]
e aí
é uma que música linda cara
é muito linda música amei em adorei
linda demais a música não sei aí
[Música]
e essa tá no meu álbum meu último álbum
lançado ambulante dá para ligar para o
base em grama essa música ela é muito
importante para mim é toda construção
desse álbum é muito importante quando a
gente escreve eu chamei meu amigo na
época para escrever junto comigo
dançavam foi muito legal eu acho que
quando a gente usa o nosso dom da
palavra o dom da música o dom da nossa
arte de para informar as pessoas para
incentivar as pessoas comportar as
pessoas a gente está fazendo um grande
papel em e um grande trabalho em
conjunto talvez o maior bem que a gente
possa estar fazendo um momento né com
certeza a gente não pode sucumbir à
e por hoje é só meu filho melhor a então
a gente fica aqui esperando o próximo da
gente tá com essas duas músicas
exatamente e a gente tem que se
contentar e na próxima a gente já vai
botar eu vou botar logo cedo para não
vir logo muito porque essa música que
gostaria demais de ouvir adorei adorei
fiquei aqui só curtindo aquela muito top
ela vai arrumar as coisas ainda uma
novidade então vamos esperar e novidade
de karol conká nos próximos dias muito
obrigado aqui tá
ah obrigada eu que agradeço valeu gente
obrigado para dias pessoal quero contigo
não é
a contar o que é a novidade tem alguma
coisa pede música música né é uma música
uma música em breve novidade é que
música logo umas coisas logo mais eu
mando para você obrigado amor tamo junto
brasil rever você quer que agradeço
precisar estamos aqui e é nós não beijo
carinhoso tamo junto aí alcançar
a karol com k karol conká acabou de
estar aqui com a gente fez altos
sonzinho temos aqui para gente você não
pode parar ii
e aí
os convidados esta pronto nossos
próximos convidados são talentos no não
há mais de 10 anos no mesmo teatro há
mais de dez anos aqui em são paulo se
apresentando e a galera curti demais meu
amigo curti demais eles também estão
presentes na internet há muito tempo
aqui no youtube também e você que ainda
não comprou seu cantinho aqui ó
e aqui clica pode comprar agora bota no
super record cê é louco hein então aí
bota aqui para mim por favor olá tudo
bem estamos aqui estamos aqui o anderson
[Risadas]
[Música]
ele ele é
oi cara tudo bem como é que vocês estão
eu queria perguntar para você o seguinte
como é que vocês estão fazendo nesse
momento que vocês não agora que eu fiz
varguista na máscara ninguém
criatividade aí nessa quarentena a gente
tá fazendo o nosso canal a gente tá
fazendo remotamente mas nosso canal
segue a gente no nosso canal do nosso
provável é
e no privado ninguém vai falar e aí você
não vai lá fazer com ele aqui então
agora por isso que a gente entrada aqui
e a tua vida você tá fotografia agora tá
tudo certo mas o meu às vezes eu já
falei assim já fiz assim ó entendeu eu
aceito aqui ó aqui embaixo não falei com
você eu falei com você semana eu achei
muito legal eu queria deixar o negócio
que você tá fazendo aqui nessa cidade eu
achei isso incrível acho que é genial eu
queria deixar aqui registrado nessa
larga essa sua ideia se iniciativa eu
espero que dê muito certo conte com a
gente porque você precisar cara tamo
junto cara a gente tem que fazer isso aí
mesmo a gente tem que ajudar o lugar
onde a gente mora fazer fazer fazer as
coisas acontecerem perto da gente né
porque senão se nem a gente
ah entendi procura lá eles escolheram
desafio para você está desafio que eles
escolheram foi botar só tem que fazer
comerciais 10 comerciais que vocês são
capaz de fazer 10 comerciais em cinco
minutos porque aqui é o seguinte 15
minutos 15 minutos eu tenho certeza que
estão espera você então a gente é muito
bom e tempo a gente fez comédia mas
agora nossa realidade é tempo e relógio
arrasado isso o relógio não pode entrar
com tudo aí 10 comerciais aqui a gente
vai coisas incríveis acontecendo uma
live só que capacidade de dançar me
tocar pedir para cléber no baixo que foi
uma coisa que você fez 10 começar a
gente vai dar uma ideia de 10 comerciais
e vai improvisar aqui eu preciso da sua
ajuda o whindersson para você pegar um
tema que o pessoal aí de um estilo de
comercial tipo comercial de banco ou sei
lá qual que é o comercial então já não
vai ler os comentários e aí o anderson
vai seu comentário junto com você e vai
falando para a gente fazer 10
propagandas improvisadas em cinco
minutos 10 quilos do senhor onde já
comercial a gente vai precisar começar a
usar também é
e hoje eu já tenho aqui ó com 40 por 40
41 por conta do neném vou deixar vou
deixar a pessoa clica aqui para você vou
deixar meu anjo para conversar com você
então tá pois tá tá então olha só vai
beleza o anderson vai dar o desafio para
a gente e é que você vai ter nos
comentários é meu lado a greve os
estilos nos comentários onde está lendo
e elidio vamos improvisar 10 comerciais
tem cinco minutos comerciais né quem
quis né mensagem bastante aí filha que
se fosse outro tipo de produto que seria
já tem um ótimo aqui maravilhoso então a
gente vai começar com porque amanhã pode
começar cinco minutos na tela contra
três valendo agora play pote o trio foi
o namorado namorado você tem um namorado
cremoso sai daqui você pegando dois
macarrões de couro de caracol e juntando
eles falam coração e melhor esse fica
pronta em 5 minutos exatamente como seu
namorado e você pode tirar ele do
freezer se colocar direto no micro-ondas
assim como o seu namorado sabia só de
american pie o melhor namorável sem
dúvida nenhuma meu deus do teu sorriso
mas primeiro eu preciso de um macarrão
em que eu possa confiar um ponto eu faço
outras coisas aí
os bancos demorando demais para me
responder esse não esse demora apenas 5
minutos novo banco da sadia agências mac
x de pedra agentes calabresa com cheddar
e agências calabresa bacon conceda
bancos tatiana kantismo feito para você
porque é tem x de queijo é bom
supermercado supermercado supermercado e
e aí jean como é que corre corre porque
aqui amanhã no whatsapp que está por
para você e seus amigos muita uma balada
que demora apenas 5 minutos para ficar
pronta você pode voltar para casa mais
cedo e comer um mac and cheese uma área
vip lá hoje de calabresa e outra aula
vip longe de bacon e uma ala vip de
pedra como é que eu tinha a festa das
festas 1
e o teu papai noel ainda entra pelo pelo
vila velha lareira é tudo passado agora
só foi nós podem chegar na sua casa pelo
micro-ondas exatamente direto do freezer
do polo norte para o seu micro-ondas
natal essa dia não é que fica natal tem
sabor né ele é sabor bacon calabresa com
cheddar e peru em dezembro calma viagens
você porque a casa cinco minutos
o que significa pronto isso significa
que em um dia aproximadamente vários
mcqueens e ficam se você está preocupado
que nem a gente quem é que vai comer
esses mais antigos a resposta pode estar
dentro do seu coração ou no canto da
mulher quem tive data dia não quer ir
e vem para a universidade italiana que
lhe diz cursos de apenas cinco minutos
saúde saúde eu preciso de um disco
microondas para vir para cá
eu não gostava daquilo nova carro é
catupiry para você vai ficar pronto em
cinco minutos parece que o tempo não meu
anjo a gente não conseguiu um
e faz o último então você não fala como
é que eu fiz quatro por quatro sabe como
é que esse carro 4 por 4 vai lá você
precisa de infração cinco minutos e às
vezes quero andar no terreno gelato por
um terreno completamente quente novo
mercantilista dia único com 5 portas
único macarrão né quente quatro por
quatro não é 16 cinco minutos boa boa
boa boa boa problema só pelo amor de
deus manda um
bom vamos lá então essa pergunta lote
com 48 e 44 na novela mexicana e eu te
amo tá tia está tia mercantilismo e
a cada dia como é que ele que se ele me
recordo uma carona que você que tá
pronto em cinco minutos está correndo um
macarrão de cheddar mas não ele também
tem calabresa entregue agora mesmo
compre para o seu pai ou será que é seu
pai a primeira novela que a metade do
elenco é brasileira outra metade ela
também pode mexicano eu não sei acho que
a gente nunca mais fazer a gente nunca
mais vai fazer nenhuma novela é
o filme de drama você pede a gente vai
filme direto com a gente pode fazer
matico é drama não trabalham então filme
de drama eu quero choro choro lá né
é isso no chão eu deixei cair eu deixei
cair um pouco eu não é preciso me
desculpa mas não dá para arrumar tem a
regra dos cinco minutos 5 segundos eu
não lembro filme de terror filme de
terror agora terei que esperar esperar a
o terror com a mesma trilha vamos lá
agora eu teria que comer ponto e produto
você vai ter que comer um macarrão com
num que engolir macarrão ou a mistura
das duas coisas com certeza né
ah tá você disse que ia aproveitar você
também pode falar você mas a gente faz
questão científica tá bom ó
e vai então ficção científica tem que
não sentir vamos tentar então aqui vamos
ver se sai alguma coisa é
e mercantis sabia parece coisa do futuro
por quê que apenas 5 minutos para ficar
pronto hoje em dia isso acabou sadia né
quente no futuro para sua casa
disponível agora também no aplicativo no
celular você aperta e sai macarrão e
você come é isso aí galera rapaz não
consegue tamo junto vocês aqui no meu
canal tamo junto ele vídeo tamo junto
barbixas valeu ainda tamos esperando
parabéns a você parabéns as a dito
é incrível maravilhosa e até a próxima a
próxima junto o beijo é nós direto de
goiânia
[Música]
g1
e sabe o que é que tá faltando tá
faltando o sertanejo já até agora já
tivemos danças mágicas improvisos raps
tudo agora sabe que tá esperando a gente
ela mesmo já está no ponto esperando
naiara azevedo aparece aqui para ver
e a lista ela sentada já no ponto de dar
o play na sua música com samsung e aí
meu querido como é que você tá tá bem
oi tudo bem tô ótima graças a deus e
vocês aí eu tô ótima cabelo incrível
desde o começo rapaz que lugar bonito aí
entra tá é a no escritório satisfatório
bonitinho viu escritório adorei adoro
interiores daquela sala do meu esposo
aqui no escritório nessa quarentena você
tá curtindo você tá botando a cabeça no
lugar rapaz eu tô mais unida que a minha
sogra do que nunca porque eu vou dar
minha casa para casa da minha sogra da
casa da minha sogra minha casa e tá aí
tamo nessa tão fechada que eu tô bem com
ela senão tava lascada então é bom para
a gente saber quem é que a gente fica
bem logo né a gente já está descobrindo
agora que a gente se dar bem e
e aí
a sejap camarim pediu agora tá na
mamadeira tô muito comigo esse medo
porque os meus pode vir cobraram muito
músicas do começo da minha caneta fiz
uma live na semana passada não tem com
todas as músicas contando a minha
história porque são 10 anos de carreira
que eu fiz esse ano né então eu procurei
assim trazer um pouco mais da minha
essência é para uma pessoa pensa assim
que eu brotei em 2016 igual bonecos de
massa o render daí não são 10 anos de
história pré história pré história pré
história então já vou ficar aqui
posicionado para dar o play aqui no
desafio e você cinco minutos só cinco
minutos coisas incríveis que acontece em
cinco minutos agora o médio é
sensacional com músicas de naiara
azevedo do início até para cá tamo junto
e a com você nayara começa a
e aí
e não vermelho é hora de parar para
refletir que passou ontem uma clima
[Música]
interfere essa ilusão que está tudo bem
e o coração brigando não é
e outra não
e aí
e eu não aguento mais ver você vindo
trapaceira amiga nós sair torto e eu vou
mudar todo meu jeito e você vai se
arrepender você vai ninguém no whatsapp
para ver se ela pode fazer amor no seu
filho tudo bem bom tá todo tempo de
alguma coisa enrolada né
e aí
um beijo na boca e eu sou curado de
noção e o meu destino eu não sei não
melinda eu sou patatá cabou o
e lembrando que tá perdida em você minha
vida não acordar de manhã eu fui dormir
não hein louco aqui você não é
é uma carta que diminuto sistema para
você
e por mais que você
a segunda é
e o meu filho não olha
e aí
a foto mais não quero mais você
e apaga o que tem vou mais você
a segunda
eu quero essa música para o meu amigo
diego de souza eliana os três que me
liberaram com tanto carinho e tudo
quanto fizer essa última canção comigo
dia todos os meus fãs fizeram parte da
minha história que lhe pediram sabe para
cantar essa música hoje homenagem minha
para todos vocês estão ligadinhos aí
novo como é que fica festival que linda
homenagem em olha aí todos os sonhos
naiara azevedo que estão aqui assistindo
muito obrigado você está aqui assistindo
a gente nesse momento estamos se unindo
aqui através de live né ultimamente o
que está dando pra gente fazer se
encontrar é desse jeito obrigado nayara
por você ter participado aqui com a
gente várias pessoas quiser eu só folha
de incríveis você acabou de dar para
gente aí o remember né pra gente
relembrar um pouquinho de como é que
você começou todo mundo tem história
e como é que as histórias né
é isso e a minha foi boa demais depois
eu vou a galera que eu terminar essa
live incrível convida para dar um pulo
lá no meu canal que tem uma cozido e
marcava documento da minha carreira que
nada que nada com certeza foi vai ser
com certeza muito legal quem for
procurar qualquer coisa que você tamo
junto é nóis um beijo um abraço teu
esposo também tá e a todos os seus
músicos aí amor beijo amor com ele o
amor tá
e aí
oi naiara azevedo naiara azevedo naiara
azevedo também não azevedo ela fala aqui
ó bota aí você mentalmente tô sarrando
em você mentalmente tô sarrando em você
mentalmente tô sarrando em você limpa
realmente lucas lucco princesinha tá
doida é tá louca é um
é que tá louca é tá doida é tá [ __ ] é
o local no qual é não deram deram deram
deram ai ai ai ai ai ai ai nós temos
mais um convidado nós temos o nosso
assistir porque todo final de festa tem
lastro meu amigo não adianta com ele
você já sabe se eu falar você vai dizer
tô só no paju chama esse rapaz para mim
aqui bota ele aqui na tela e
e aí
e aí está ele hein e aí como é que você
tá bebê tranquilo e você meu irmão sai
esperando você agitar aqui para gente eu
estou muito ansioso tava acompanhando
todo mundo que passou e estou muito
ansioso para chegar meia hora de acabou
de chegar tá preparado para voltar não
então preparado rapaz você sempre alguns
cenários maravilhosos aí viu assistir
sua live aquele cenário eu vou pular de
led você você é louco você você é muito
massa tamo junto eu já vou falar para
ele viu eu vou aqui ó eu vou aqui no
novo especial ii
oi gente eu vou fazer também é o mesmo
tempo você vai mais eu vou fazer também
com certeza uns 5 minutinhos agora você
vai ver coisa que ele que acontece em
cinco minutos você abre rapidinho não
tem muita dificuldade bota ali dentro
fechou colocou cinco minutos e dá o play
e já está valendo só palavra pedro
sampaio e
e aí
as coisas acontecem né
é a prova viva que coisas incríveis
acontecem cinco minutos completo 1
e aí
um trabalho de
o sampaio corrêa
o pedro sampaio pedro sampaio cinco
minutos cinco meses cinco minutos cinco
minutos cinco minutos e
o que é isso meu irmão que show foi esse
que você apresentou para gente rapaz
agora tem que comer também cara
e nós já estamos comidos aqui já está
tudo direitinho cada qual já está com
seu você que ainda não tem o seu ainda
aqui no cantinho da tela do lado de cá
você consegue só vendo aqui bebê
consegue na tela dele aqui no cantinho
você pode virar o seu celular que já vai
saber como adquirir facilmente e aí cara
quanto tempo demora para fazer um
negócio é
15 minutos para produzir então tá fácil
demais a gente que tá devagar eu já vou
comprar um negócio aqui também daquele
daqui viu dele
eu gostei desse aqui ó essa daqui 5
minutos consegue fazer de qualquer coisa
do jeito que tá aí mas você tem que
programar cada botãozinho
e é isso aí eu eu programo cada botão eu
antes programei na verdade esse essa voz
aqui é do comercial do mac x mesmo assim
não quem quiser pesquisar lá tá lá
começar a dançar dinheiro do mac x e a
mulher fala isso aqui já tem cinco
minutos consegue comer e play on
a comer tocando consegue dar uma
colherada e que toca alguma coisa
e claro não tá bom então tá com pão aí
agora quero ver eu quero ver desafio
aquela lampada ali ó
e aí ele vai ficar fechado true true
[Música]
true
e aí
a ver bruna sampaio salão uma mão só
o show de bola meu amor você é top
demais aí sim viu aí sim cara que prazer
estar aqui com você que fazer falar aqui
com você e você tem alguma outra música
para tocar para gente uma todinha aí
destacar o play quanto você come mas
você vai dançar não pode ser aprende
dançar fazer mais não não vai ter que
claro hoje você já fez o quê hoje mágica
que mais hoje já fiz mágica eu já fiz
maquiagem entendeu humor também já fiz
já cantei já imitei também já improvisei
fiz rap texto agora é só você mandar o
som então bota mão no joelho agora a
gente vai bota a mão no joelho vai
a preservar no vídeo ela vem vem vem
e tenta falar no vídeo eu quero quero
quero quero quero quero quero três é
demais fãs
boa tarde atrás ó
me chama tá bom eu tento rebolando
chamando seu nome tanto tanto tanto
tanto tanto tanto rebolar rebolar
rebolar se aprende a mão no teu nome
sampaio em
nós tamo junto tá mas só mais um
pouquinho tro tro tro tamo junto meu pai
é nós é hora de lanchar de jantar queria
mandar um beijo também para julinha e
carol do dante um beijo para vocês duas
estão acompanhando a gente aqui para
todo mundo do meu também está presente
no virtual um beijo para todos vocês que
estão aí eu vi a tela virtual você
e obrigado meu irmão boa quarentena para
você fique bem fique em paz fique com
sua família é nós meu beijo carinhoso é
nós estamos já você quer mandar saideira
para nós
o rapaz foi com medo de que manda vamos
embora mas o meu trabalho aqui dentro
depois dar o play
o passatempo não é
e aí
e o movimento sensuais o movimento é bem
flexível do mundo o
se movimentar o movimento agora vamos
pagar o
a máquina cinco minutos daqui 15 minutos
como é que é isso aí meu irmão você que
agora eu tô dizendo que você é o cara
esse é o fera dos dedos em sala dele
pedir tem nada menos que com certeza com
certeza sensibilidade que sabe entendeu
eu vou dar você mas quero pedir para
você oab direto exatamente local certo
você só pedir a você para não se não
sair porque eu vou eu vou chamar a
galera toda que participou aqui da lá e
para tar junto com você aqui agora para
gente fazer uma tela bonita aqui
passando o globo esporte aqui falando
com jogadores na copa do mundo tá eu
peço deixou uma notícia apareceu de nojo
é queimar a gente telefone e aversões
apareceram de novo aí em 5 minutos
15 minutos 15 minutos
e a letícia aí ó vai precisar usar o pai
para a gente karol conká cantor aqui
para gente também todo mundo aqui
comendo o seu já terminou o dele o meu
só tem um retiro que eu não comer já
detonei
[Música]
e aí
o hotel cinco minutos brasil dentro aqui
na cozinha você cometeu ele bonitinho um
partes ali na produção dividir a tela do
edi com cinco minutos rapidinho
agradecer a você que participou que
mostrou o seu talento aqui agradecer a
sadia tá bom reunido todo mundo aqui
porque a gente não estaria reunindo todo
mundo que não fosse tá dia obrigado por
essa oportunidade maravilhosa tá bem o
a cada um bota isso aqui eu queria
agradecer o meu amigo pedro sampaio e
pelo aquele deu a gente aqui nessa logo
após aí operou ainda para comer letícia
tá mandando mandando brasa ali alerta
também estou cozinha sensacional é isso
aí meu cabelo é ninguém me avisou né
bacana meu batom não vê que falou isso
boca rosa obrigado leite por essa boca
aqui obrigado todo mundo que está aí
obrigado você quer acompanhar aqui até
agora obrigado que estavam aqui na tela
falando obrigado você que estava
comprando pelo youtube ou pelas hashtag
nas redes sociais muito obrigado estadia
pelo convite obrigado a todos os
participantes ligado barbicha tiago
montalti felipe barbieri karol conká
letícia tem mais meu deus que mais
e rashid também vem naiara azevedo nossa
muito obrigado todo mundo que participou
muito obrigado a todo mundo que esteve
aqui até o final com a gente em tamo
junto e nós eu queria chamar antes o
pedro sampaio vai deixar as musiquinhas
para gente para gente sair em clima de
festa nem clima de ar ter tamo junto vem
para cá para ele papai não toque mais
não é para gente
e aí
o papai fica especialmente desculpa
cinco minutos cinco minutos 5 minutos já
[Música]
é
a morena não tem cinco minutos pronto em
cinco minutos a gente não tem começo
cinco cinco cinco cinco cinco cinco
e como é que é nós é
a segunda
g1
e olha esta imagem parece globo esporte
e começa agora e ontem o ferroviário